one of my favorite parts about this
movie was Carol's friendship with Maria
so I was wondering what was it like
meeting leshawna for the first time and
is there anything about her
interpretation of that role that wound
up really surprising you oh the Shona is
is so powerful and I think you know when
you look at this movie you think of it
it's like oh we're talking about female
empowerment we're talking about female
strength and what leshawna brings is
like of another very specific aspect of
like commanding herself and commanding a
room that is so powerful and she's also
an incredible pilot in this film so
there's just like hyper intelligence and
like great judgment calls happening from
her certain actors when you work with
them it just feels like there's like
nobody else in the room and you can kind
of drop in and that's what it was like
with her especially in those moments
that dusk shot
I really just believed everything she
was saying it was like felt like she was
talking to me talking to you too it was
like there's a lot of things in this
movie that I felt like it was talking
point I appreciate that the hope I was
reading though that initially you were
hesitant to sign on for this with
everything that comes with signing on
for a Marvel movie so now that you're
firmly in the thick of it right now
looking back was there any particular
key to just enjoying the ride and also
getting comfortable with all the
craziness happening around you I think
the training is really like what has
prepared me not just for this presser
but maybe just for the rest of my life
is learning that I was putting too much
limitation on myself that I was deciding
what I was capable of before trying and
I never would have thought that I could
have gotten as strong as I did like
physically and once I started
experiencing that I was like whoa
there's must be so many other elements
of myself I had experienced little
glimmers of these too when it comes to
just like the fact that I'm an introvert
and doing stuff like this is really hard
for me and requires a lot of self-care
outside of sitting in these chairs doing
this but I'm growing and I'm learning
I'm learning what kind of life I want to
live and this was just like too big
of an opportunity for me to step away
from because I was scared you know
speaking of the idea of self-care and
also just talking to someone who I think
always tells it like it is one of my
favorite parts about superhero movies
across the board is the fan community
around them but every once in a while
little toxicity creeps into that fandom
so what would you say to a superhero
movie lover who encounters that in the
fandom what should they do
oh I mean who cares honestly love what
you love
who cares what other people think I need
to put that in my back pocket for
another time someone may mean to you on
the Internet I mean it's just another
day I'm sorry
because I'm gonna remember that and just
brush it off brush it off who cares you
know who you are it's true most
important question of this interview
tell me something so bizarre about
yourself that a scroll couldn't even
come up with it oh no these questions
are so hard I'm like how do I know it's
bizarre I think I'm very normal by the
way there's me and the other rooms I'll
tell you that I've heard some
interesting things so far really some
very bizarre things yeah our thing
I think Jude is winning this at this
point hey what is his he told me that
when he was a kid he painted a bike that
he had gold but then also decided to
paint himself gold so he can match the
bike and swears there's a picture of
this honestly I'm give up I actually
feel like I've always thought I was a
weirdo but now I actually feel very
normal because I did not do that made me
feel better about myself too
[Music]